i would be flat out well
i would be flat out lying if i said i
was disappointed if i said i wasn't
disappointed
of course it's a bit
disappointing it's just disappointing
most people here just to say the least
will be disappointed and i'm being kind
when i say that not as excited as i i
was this morning
mcauliffe
made several mistakes unfortunately
there's many things that they call it
probably could and should have done
better like allowing yunkan to beat him
to the punch on certain issues like
taxes and he allowed
that
himself
rightly or wrongly to be defined as
anti-parents look at that debate
where you did the education thing yeah i
think the grassroots support wasn't
there the grassroots campaigning wasn't
there like it's been with many other
campaigns some of the ineptitude of the
biden administration
around the afghan
withdrawal and the delta variant
as well as some of the you know uh the
stalemate in congress is all affecting
things locally because
biden was then was not able it hasn't
been and uh and uh congress have not
been able to get to the two bills
that has dragged his approval rating
down as well as national democrats no
getting around that one thing is i don't
feel that
the republicans have to tell the truth
you can't lower
taxes and then
increase education spending funding and
of course you have yanking playing this
game off on the one hand appealing to
the trump base
with all his dog whistles and at the
same time you know sort of staying
appealing to the moderates with all his
push for education and economy youngkin
ran a good campaign i think
unfortunately